foreign
I joined the British royal Navy at the
tender age of 17 and in three decades of
service lived and worked in every ocean
I witnessed firsthand the Hidden World
of the high seas sometimes the only
vessel for hundreds of miles
and other times I'd wake up surrounded
in a fishing fleet that despite having
powerful technology at my fingertips I
didn't really know who they were or what
they've been doing
it is a wild west out there and Rogue
fishes
Rogue fishes are extracting well the the
disobeying the laws that we put in place
to protect our ocean and its resources
and their pillaging
colossal amounts of fish
Seafood
one fifth of seafood is thought to be
caught illegally or is simply unreported
and that's a crime worth up to 23 and a
half billion dollars
and it's a crime that skews the science
so it affects the sustainability of our
Fisheries
it threatens the health of our Ocean and
the well-being of millions of people
mainly in poorer countries
and it's not just pirate fishing
that's threatened in the future of our
ocean
out at Sea all spills are going
undetected and therefore unpunished
there's a massive unmonitored growth in
shipping oil and gas exploration
and aquaculture as I mentioned just a
few and this is piling pressure
on a notion that's already stressed by
climate change
the straightforward fact is
if you can't see it you can't manage it
and I know from experience you can't
monitor the whole ocean from the decks
of ships
but you come from space and these are
interesting times because seemingly
intractable problems are starting to
yield to the power of Technology
Ai and global interconnectedness
up there right now there's thousands of
satellites beaming back an enormous
amount of data from the remotest parts
of our ocean
what if we could harness that data make
it useful and available to people who
care about the ocean
well thanks to Rapid advances in
technology and AI we can do that
using GPS location data and machine
learning Global fishing watch built the
first ever live stream map to monitor
the industrial fishing fleet at the
moment we see some 70 000 vessels
we've made this information public and
freely available to the world
but technology moves on thank you
technology moves on rapidly there's new
and emerging technology that we need to
embrace in order to give this picture to
everybody who needs it like when we're
working with our partners in Japan and
South Korea they told us there was
illegal fishing suspected in North
Korean Waters in contravention of the UN
sanctions there but when we first took a
look on our map we could see very little
fishing because those vessels were not
sharing their GPS location data as they
should we call them dark vessels and
generally dark vessels are up to no good
so we had to turn to other sources of
data we looked at
satellite-based radar and Optical
imagery and we lit that region up we
revealed an armada of almost a thousand
vessels
it's one of the largest cases of illegal
fishing ever seen
with this huge human impact too tragedy
because the smaller more rickety North
Korean boats could not compete with that
vas Fleet they were pushed further and
further out to sea and as a result
hundreds of them would be capsized to be
washed ashore in Japan with the crew
either starving or dead
we made our findings public and as a
result
we compelled the authorities to take
action illegal fish in that region has
dropped by 75 and we're not seeing
hundreds of vessels now washing Shore in
Japan
the good news is
the techniques we use to illuminate what
was happening in North Korea we can use
anywhere
and everywhere to make the invisible
visible today any of you can click on
the internet to explore
roads and buildings on land why can't we
do the same for the ocean we need to
create
a dynamic complete map of all industrial
activity out at Sea and make it
available to everybody for free
well thanks to the audacious Community
we're going to do that using GPS
location data
and millions of gigabytes of satellite
imagery we'll use AI to map and monitor
more than a million ocean-grown vessels
we'll monitor the entire industrial
fishing fleet and those dark vessels
we'll add in hundreds of thousands of
cargo vessels tens of thousands of oil
and gas structures
aquaculture farms and wind farms with
this public information
conservationists will have the
information they need to protect
critical habitats like National
Geographic pristine Seas they're using
our data to help work with governments
and communities to protect critical
habitats in Seven Marine parks with a
combined area of more than twice that of
California
and we're going to give researchers the
data they need to advance ocean science
and we're going to give the media
campaigners and the public powerful
knowledge about human activity out at
Sea and this comes just in time because
after two decades of talking we finally
have a treaty to manage the conservation
of ocean life and the establishment of
marine protected areas out on our ocean
and this is going to be critical because
there are 200 almost 200 countries have
committed to protecting 30 of the ocean
by 2030 and they will need tools like
this to uphold that promise
we can develop the tools the governments
need to uphold their commitments we can
inspire a new wave of ocean management
through public data
and open technology
now I might have salt in my veins but
you don't need to have sail the seven
seas to care about the future of the
ocean all life on Earth depends on it
it's providing the oxygen we breathe
it's regulating our climate
and it's providing the food that
billions of people
rely on but ocean resources are not
inexhaustible we've got to protect him
we have a chance to do that today like
never before we can give a free Open
Access monitoring system for the entire
ocean together we can reign in
this outdooration
we can end pirate fishing and we can
transform ocean management for the
common good of all
thank you